so you remember when we made that video
about Iman godzi kinda yeah he's an
absolute G and because we were such good
people apparently and he liked us
decided to send us some gifts what I
know Christmas came early seriously
what is this
wait what this is a vocal he said you
were sure microphone are you kidding oh
my God
are you sure this is from him
who else would it be Santa yes only
Santa does things like this that's wild
we each got one of these microphones
that's pretty pimp that's so cool really
really really nice like I could cry well
there's more get cryish on things again
and get gifts oh my God this is like
really generous and nice okay okay
that's crazy this life's not bad but
it's this these are way better this is
beautiful it smells like women [ __ ] so
this is probably for you it smells good
Okay candles 34 Boulevard Saint Germain
that's crazy I was just watching iman's
video of his of his tour he sent us
candles from first
oh my God open them up
I am really trying not to cry because
I'm very like I can't believe this it's
like
in a thing and it's gorgeous
so oh my God
my room's about to smell so good your
room better bring the hose back and be
like oh is this from Paris um
absolutely
gorgeous it's an essential so you put
the oil in in the thing and then you put
these little sticks in and then it
smells it makes the house smell
Beautiful That's crazy all right this is
this is some luxury here I I can't even
thank you
it's because you're so handsome oh yeah
thank you that's actually crazy because
I was literally just watching his video
thinking that would be nice to get some
candles candles are such a nice touch I
can't believe all these beautiful gifts
and I'm so grateful and I don't even
know what to say except you're not
watching the show you better be because
this is the kind of person he has super
intelligent very successful and
obviously also kind and generous this
this is a gorgeous candle look at that
oh that smells bomb did you eat and
that's just that one I'm not gonna open
all of them right now little lady being
so into candles but those are pretty
good it's really nice oh [ __ ] and two
microphone stands come on rode
microphones
damn this is so convenient because with
the new content I'm about to start
making too that's perfect I can't even
this is just I don't even know what to
say I cannot wait to set all this stuff
up first of all this just takes
everything to the next level I mean you
have a nice setup here but this takes
everything to just super pro level Kobe
he'll take he'll take better care of the
gifts than he did that box third
generation USB audio interface so this
is so all the microphones and stuff can
go through this one thing I'm assuming
so he's been getting these packages and
I've been saying what's in the box
what's in the box he's like I don't know
I don't know we'll find out and uh and I
said like is there some surprise coming
I think I need to know about but he
didn't tell me until just now and I
could actually like I just can't even
believe that that's wild I never thought
I'd be getting gifts from making YouTube
videos Iman thank you brother thank you
Iman you're so cool
we're gonna I'll give I'll give you some
gifts in return one day I'll leave the
links to all of Iman godzi's social
medias in the description thank you so
much and wish money later
you're crying you're pretty good it's
really nice
it's okay Mommy
no need to cry
it's just
a night into that things are going right
oh you're so sweet that's somebody
somebody you know else believes in you
what an awesome oh so sweet
it's very nice okay all right
thank you Iman
oh my God
[Music]